oolette cav show special guest
the big three just dropped ladies and
gentlemen
my guy roddy rich yes
compton is in the building man what's
going on champion it's been a minute
since i've seen i haven't seen you uh i
mean i think i saw you a couple of like
little parties or something but i really
ain't like locked in with you i feel
like since before the pandemic man
it's been a minute bro
how are you though i'm chilling bro
everything's good you feeling good
always
yo uh dropping these three records kind
of give me um
the thought process behind
because i know you've been teasing feed
the streets volume three
so what is the purpose of you know
giving us a little sampler a little a
little taste before you uh you give us
the next project
sure i'm really just ready to drop music
bro i'm just ready to drop
ready to get a fans what they want to
hear just give them some more music and
stay in tune with them feed them i mean
yeah do you feel like um
do you feel like the feedback to the
second album lit a fire under you to
like get back to kind of just
putting the foot on the neck in terms of
just dropping because you know we had
pandemic obviously you dropped a number
one album the pandemic happens
was it two and a half years since i
think just two it's about two years
since you know in between albums but i
feel like
you know sometimes you take
a situation like you know some of the
feedback you were getting some people
let it kind of shake them but i feel
like you're like super locked in right
now i heard all three records they're
crazy
yeah i mean i ain't really like
i feel like [ __ ] i'm about to go gold
feel me sell 500 000 copies i know a lot
of [ __ ] that don't even do that so
most people don't do that really so i
just feel like [ __ ]
it's a body of work i feel like
maybe if they didn't enjoy it it wasn't
for them that's fair that's fair um how
far along are you with feed the streets
three
[ __ ] i mean it's just it's more of a
movement lifestyle more so right now
it's just uh you know just a state of
being where i'm at okay it ain't really
a project i wouldn't say i feel like i
just want to do more when it comes to
you know
when it comes to feeding my fast outside
the music is just more so um
you know just
activations uh traveling and being able
to touch different people and you know
help those who need to be helped it's
more of a movement than anything that's
fair
so you spent a hundred thousand dollars
at tootsies in miami this is the thing
that actually happened
yeah that's a serious amount of money in
tootsies did you how many fried lobster
tails with seafood rice did you order
there all right every time it's the best
right yeah yeah are you getting the
shoulder rub are you having the massage
lady rub you down every time people
don't even realize it's not even like a
dancer who rubs your shoulders because a
lot of people haven't been to tootsie's
because they hear drake rapping about it
just like there's like legit
masseuses watching five you feel me it's
like
you know it's just more so a vibe like
that's
when you go to miami
just trying to vibe and that that's like
one of them like one of my favorites you
go to tootsies you get the fried lobster
tail and you get a massage yeah you get
rubbed down kicking it it's a vibe for
sure
is that the most you've spent at a strip
club
i wouldn't even consider it a strip club
like that it's more so just
a place to just vibe like
we listen to our own music in there
we'll be in our own world i'll be after
the studio and just more so it's just a
chill time for me
what is your outside of la is
is miami up there as far as your
favorite city outside of la to visit i
mean that's like
i lived there too so you got a crib
there that's that's what's going on type
[ __ ] nice
and
no state tax if you live in miami yeah
it's more of a back and forth situation
like but your primary residence should
be in florida you'll save a lot of money
no i feel that too i feel that too it's
just
you know i get the money to engine more
so just a peace of mind is over all that
[ __ ] you know what i'm saying yeah being
able to be just kicking it
and just be cool
like that's what i'd be [ __ ] without
there um
you obviously reuniting with mustard on
on the first track on this one uh what
is it about
you and mustard's chemistry you think
that just makes everything so special
every time y'all link on on a join i
just feel like you guys
are batting a thousand percent man
always yeah no i didn't i just feel like
we is more so big like everything is big
it's deeper than rap more so with me and
him it's just more so we got so many
songs it's just time to just give them
out at this point like we gotta just go
ahead and just
do what we need to do because i just
feel like the west is like we gotta just
give them what they want we gotta we
gotta be the ones that they spinning and
we gotta stay on their neck more
would you and mustard ever do a full
collab project is that i know i'm facing
a thousand percent is that something you
guys like seriously consider doing a
thousand percent
how many records that we haven't heard
are just in honestly just a lot a lot
it's more to count it's more than you
can count more so we got ideas
songs with other [ __ ] we got our own
[ __ ] like we just we just vibe like it's
for our past like all right we're going
to do a project bro we go you know it's
just like we just more so
homies brothers like more on that type
of time so it's like whenever we in
whatever city we go heap loading beats
i'm rapping on them [ __ ] that ain't no
like
expectation from it i feel like that's
why we get the best results because it's
not no
pressure would it count us 100 um post
malone somebody who embraced you really
early
um
uh like i said i'm looking forward to
the tour that's coming out obviously
cooped up is crazy yeah uh
talk about y'all's friendship because
he's a great guy somebody you can hang
out with get drunk with you know what
i'm saying i've lost a beer pong a bunch
of times against him yeah yeah
talk about that friendship man uh like i
said he a real [ __ ] more so than
anything i feel like this is just a full
circle moment that's doing this tour
together as more so just
speaks volumes of him and our
relationship our friendship he took me
out on the road and he had already sold
out the europe tour so just getting back
on the road with him and doing it the
right way is feel like perfect timing
for like
a good time to do that [ __ ] have you uh
ever participated in a game of beer pong
against postie yeah
yeah did you hang in there
yeah i'd be cool bro that [ __ ] don't
really bother me like
i don't really get drunk like that to be
honest what's the go to like if you're
drinking though are you i've everyone's
been on tequila really since the
pandemic started so yeah does it mean
are you still on the tequila what are we
doing the tequila cool uh you know
i feel like
i need to really just make my own
tequila that's like that would be the
that would be the play
yeah everyone's got uh uh
though
how'd you gotta be to make your own
tequila i think 25.
really like to sponsor it in
[ __ ] i think so damn same with cars you
can't sponsor a car company well you
know you can't rent a car
by yourself unless you're 25
but i'm saying like you can't even you
if you're 25 like i couldn't like like i
remember that i'm in the position i mean
[ __ ] uh no you're you're obviously if i
just mean in general like guys can't
even write cards unless you're 25. no i
know what you're saying that's why i'm
just i'm [ __ ] i'm grateful be in the
position i ain't got a rent how many
cars
[Music]
[Music]
so give me your favorite car and your
most expensive car that you own
uh
my favorite car my first car my hellcat
the one i bought in 20
18 19
20 20 um
it's a daytona edition
yeah okay uh i think they made like 500
of those it's inc inside the first car i
got with blue stitching oh nice
blue detail and [ __ ] and then i put it
on 4g that's like my favorite car but
uh my most expensive cars is derozan uh
and uh rory
the ferrari yeah yeah the ferrari's uh
it's a serious boy man both of them have
cool
yeah i feel like any car that i could go
that fast and i'm probably i'm just i'm
freaked out about it yeah i got
something else for the ass though i'm
about to do some [ __ ] ain't nobody ever
did
well probably [ __ ] done did it but
not in the last 10 years what
get a new car
fire [ __ ]
fire [ __ ] like an old school nah some
new [ __ ]
but whatever well what is it that you
haven't done that people haven't done in
10 years they got to see it
you know if i said air to your feeling
it's going to air [ __ ] don't see it
and they just gonna try to do it i'ma
just pop up with that [ __ ]
though you getting the old school hummer
nah i don't know i'm just trying to
figure out i'm thinking 10 years ago i'm
thinking 10 years ago no i'm saying that
a [ __ ] ain't dead like i ain't seen
nobody really bust it
so it's time for me to just go ahead and
make that my lane even would you
consider yourself a car enthusiast
no i just like i just like cars like
it's just a thing i like cars i like
uh diamonds and i like certain shells
obviously there's a lot of there's a lot
of uh diamonds on your neck man that's a
it's a serious amount of uh of ropes
yeah
shout out to your jeweler whoever did
those is definitely uh
appreciating your
your your your customership for sure
best jewel in the game who's your who's
your driller
elliot
shout out to elliott yeah he got wayne
though he got a future he got some
[ __ ] that's spending more money to me
what up y'all hey we got to stop the
interview to tell you about our partners
the presenting sponsor of the bootleg
kit podcast our family at odd socks man
they're dropping so much heat at odd
socks right now go to
oddssoxofficial.com use the promo code
bootleg kev one word bootleg kev you
will save 20 off at checkout listen they
got the socks you know what i mean shout
out to the ninja turtles uh i totally
just dropped my
mic flag
and then they got the odd socks basics
which are just kind of like these boys
my favorites i love the odd socks basics
and let's not forget ladies and
gentlemen odd socks now has the
underwear that's right tapatio draws on
that ass
remember oddsoxofficial.com use that
promo code bootleg kev save 20 off at
checkout let's get back to the podcast
hey you're very um i feel like in the
last couple of years you've been very
selective
about who you do records with like i
feel like a lot of people would be in
your position and we'd hear them on a
lot more other artists project but i
feel like with you
um
like when you hop on a track it's very
like few and far between
42 doug record the nle chopper record um
what is it like that has to click for
you to like actually get on some [ __ ]
cuz i'm sure if you wanted to you could
be on everyone's [ __ ] album you know
what i'm saying
is there i just feel like
just my personality
i'm selected with my women i'm selected
with even music selected wit the clothes
i put on i'm selected with the people i
hang around is just more so lifestyle so
you know when it comes to business
sometimes people may think it's a little
crazy for me to turn down a lot of [ __ ]
but i just gotta [ __ ] with it too
and you got you have to like really [ __ ]
with the person or be at least be a fan
of what they're doing exactly yeah more
so you know because a lot of times you
know
i just don't i don't want nobody singing
along to a song that i'm on and i don't
really like the song that's just the
simplicity of it do you ever look back
at some of the old [ __ ] you you did
before maybe like you were in the
position you're in now and like be like
damn
because you know i feel like most
artists when you're on that independent
grind yeah you might pull up in a city
you might get a bag for a feature you
might get a bag for a hook you know what
i'm saying like
i feel like we all have been there
before but everybody has for sure just
me being who i am at this point i feel
like i just stand more firm on what i
believe and i just do what i want to do
at this point whatever happened to
the drake song i know there was at least
one
yeah
like why did we never i remember you
were telling me in head about them i
think we're at real street fest and and
we're talking about it but like whatever
happened to the drake [ __ ] dropping like
why did that never come out
i don't really know honestly
fair enough i'm not sure you have a lot
of songs that don't come out but
obviously you know that's yeah i mean
like bro me i don't bank on doing no
song with nobody bro you talking to a
[ __ ] i went diamond by myself
i don't
yeah when you think of a record like the
box
that's a song that um
i think of like how you know there's a
lot of records like jay-z and kanye's in
paris rowdy rich is the box like where
you would be in the club
you can play that [ __ ] for 15 minutes
straight
back to back to back
there's probably like three or four of
those in the last like 15 years yeah and
that's one of them
that's hard like it's crazy to like
think i appreciate that that's crazy
that's hard bro i mean [ __ ] i'm sure
you've been in the club where they
brought that [ __ ] i mean that no i mean
yeah but when you yeah i mean [ __ ] yeah
that's that's that's hard though [ __ ]
diamond record man yeah yeah have you
thought of um because i think like you
also are getting these get in this bag
where
um
you kind of get on your r b [ __ ] i'm
thinking of the high fashions the late
at nights you know what i'm saying like
we're [ __ ] for the ladies have you ever
thought about
putting out like a
a little pack of a bunch of those
it could come you feel me it's just all
how i feel i feel like that's just a
portion of who i am when it comes to
that type of music you know i'm you know
i'm cool with a lot of i have a lot of
female friends
cool wit and you know that's just a part
of my life like gotta cater to them and
a lot of the times
the [ __ ] gonna listen to what the
females is listening to for sure so it's
like [ __ ] i just
sometimes i like to cater to them and i
like to make songs for them yeah any uh
videos shot off of these three that we
just dropped
yeah real talk um real talks crazy yeah
we did the video for that already shot
yeah i directed it yo your videos are
[ __ ] getting to the point where
they're like little movies bro like
appreciate that for real like i've been
i remember like back in the day with jd
films shooting this [ __ ] it was very
like on the spot like but even then you
feel me we had the vision and even then
there was there was like light concepts
going on you know what i'm saying yeah
no we had the vision like that's why i
said i've been directing my videos since
i came out that's just part of my
artistry so now i just get i'm blessed
to be able to work with you know um you
know great creators and experiences you
feel me it's just like the exes and the
[ __ ] i looked at their videos when i
was young
um you know so and you're blessed to be
able to execute a lot of your visions to
the fullest right yeah so cause
sometimes when you're coming up and
you're hungry and you might have a great
great idea but ideas take money
sometimes to execute you know sometimes
but i feel like [ __ ] with every season
or die young or a lot of that [ __ ] it
was still our idea and it just we was we
was limited to just our circumstances so
that's just what we showed and i feel
like that's what made it so pure and
that's what made people [ __ ] with it but
now at this point it's just like we
we accessible to
we have access to a lot more and i feel
like that's just where we at and i want
to feed my fans that as well i don't
want to limit them to what we will you
know cancel them out of what we
accessible to that's fair that's fair
yeah yeah um
i heard someone say recently that per
capita compton has produced the best
rappers ever
guys like yourself the game kendrick
cube i mean i mean cubes you know
obviously bunch of millions in south
central yeah but i think of nwa straight
out of context
easy
but i'm curious
you know uh kendrick dropped a body of
work that um
to me you really had to sit with to
really uh fully appreciate it i'm just
curious your thoughts on the kendrick
album if you got to sit with it
yeah i mean i've been a lot a lot i've
been working on my own [ __ ] but
i've been listening to tidbits and
pieces of it and i you know i feel like
i understand that
he's in a place where he's putting music
out to
push the culture forward and even just
get us to
make different [ __ ] and it's still
sticking at the same time so it's just
like that's what it's about at the end
of the day just doing what you want to
do and creating the art that you could
be proud of and you feel me i feel like
he does an amazing job at that and
putting our work together and
releasing it to the people and i should
be i'm curious um la has i feel like
right now we're in a great space as a
city in terms of just the talent that's
bubbling
in los angeles
um
i feel like a lot of people are working
together as to where maybe like four or
five years ago was felt a little
segregated um who are some of the young
la artists that got your attention man
that you're that you're just a fan of
from you know and i know you got your
guys that that are in your circle that
are dope but like
who are you [ __ ] with
[ __ ] i feel like [ __ ] uh beano and blast
is doing it they dug
blast is crazy bino's crazy yeah they
doing they thug and
another young homie uh from content
name is uh siete see i think hard yeah
he's doing this thug and he and change
in the game you feel me
as we should i feel like all the guys
i'm naming you know
they they they doing it and they lane
and they and they stick it to their
thing so i can always [ __ ] with that you
hear me like definitely a [ __ ] just
being himself and doing this stuff
yo you've gotten to the point of famous
where you can't even go to a basketball
game without people assuming that you're
dating that person like at what point
was there a specific moment
where you realized [ __ ] was just
different like
like [ __ ] really is different now like
you can't move the way you maybe used to
move you was there like a specific
moment where you just kind of realized
like [ __ ] like i don't be tripping like
at the end of the day
i just move how i want to and i feel
like in that evening i'm i'm able to
still
be discreet and do my own thug like
um
you know i just feel like [ __ ] the world
is gonna think whatever they want to but
at the end of the day i just i move cool
i don't bother nobody don't nobody
bother me you feel me and i [ __ ] with
who i [ __ ] with you know it's just that
that's how i'd be really that's fair man
um i know you're sitting on a bunch of
music
i'm curious
how many different times because over a
two-year period we went obviously
you had your first tour which
was crazy because you were you were
performing in venues that um
we're big but but for as big as the
album was
you know
the tour was already booked so you were
selling out like
two thousand seat cedars you know what
i'm saying but i don't feel like you
really had the moment
that
you deserve to have touring wise because
the pandemic hit
um
how did you deal with like
kind of having to sit down
i know you lost out on a lot of festival
money because that summer was gonna be
crazy for you like did you just
like how did you redirect all that
energy like in the middle of the
pandemic that [ __ ] was kind of crazy the
first like six or seven months man yeah
i feel like it's all in god's time and
then
you know i feel like um just
who i am i just always accept that you
feel me what god has for me is for me
and what is not is not and you know a
lot of people would be frustrated or
flustered by that but
i honestly didn't miss out on any sleep
i actually got a good chance to be
around um my family and you know be able
to
get stronger relationships with people
that you know actually
care about a [ __ ] so that's more
important than giving me uh being on the
stage or doing anything and i love my
fans and i've had the luxury of being
able to end the pandemic and
i'm still doing what i love and i still
i'm still doing what i do so that's just
in itself that's like a blessing you
feel me i always look at the positives i
don't try to look at it like it was a
bad thing necessarily because i might
not have been ready for it and you feel
me you know that that's that's what that
could have been so i could have been
ready for it i couldn't but god knew so
he just made my path how he make it yeah
i feel like a lot of people
instead of focusing on the positive of
any situation that was let the negative
take him out bro like you got to look at
the positive in every situation yeah bro
because at the end of the day if you got
a negative mindset you're gonna attract
that energy to you and that's never good
for nobody and
like i always tell my young homies it's
just like [ __ ]
it's just about what you can give to the
world it ain't about what the world can
give to you and that's game from nipsey
you feel me it's like more so
you gotta give your all to this [ __ ] the
game don't really owe you nothing nobody
owes you anything you feel me just just
as much as
i could be doing it i could not be doing
it so i just take my blessings with a
smile you feel me where do you keep the
grammy for racks in the middle at the
crib where's it at my office
that's a that's a
man it's a big
big award and that specific award just
meant so much i feel like to so many
people you know what i'm saying
like uh shout out to hip boy did you get
in with hit boy at all in terms of like
just recently like i feel like
that record is so iconic i feel like i
could only be right whatever project
that's coming you guys got gets get one
on i feel like we gotta we got a lot of
joints but you feel me it's just about
time in it just figuring out what fits
you feel me like honestly the wrecks in
the middle [ __ ] i had did that after i
did like six songs with with pluto i did
that song and my voice was wasn't
it wasn't um i could i was hoarse you
didn't take songs of the future yeah
that night and
then when i ended up doing that one last
one because i had to get in with it and
could we be just going in after that
initial first song that was the first
song i deal with it boy and then we kept
doing music and so that's why i said
it's like timing because with that song
i if nifty wouldn't have picked it you
know i probably would have just been
like alright that's another one we got
yeah we had to figure it out later and
i mean honestly you know it's just about
timing with this [ __ ] like it ain't it
ain't no
like with me and mustard it ain't really
no pressure like
we don't be like oh we gonna drop on
these [ __ ] are we gonna sell this many
records like we've sold down there 20
million records together and never
been like [ __ ] we have to sell these
records it just happens just happens
organically yeah yeah you only like over
overthinking it that's what happens
people would think [ __ ] yo you we just
can't pass over six songs with future in
one night yeah
this kind of [ __ ] happens a lot where
you hear like artists like yo i got 25
songs with kanye or some [ __ ] it's like
yo where do these songs end like where
are they at like are we ever going to
hear them i mean
i'm just i'm the type of guy bro i just
work a lot
like i work a lot on my way to my radio
station
interviews and stuff i'm on the calls
with you for me to touring people and i
just i just be working a lot workaholic
i'm sure that i'm sure the live show is
gonna be crazy on this definitely yo
what up man we got to stop the interview
real quick to tell you about our good
folks at blue chew that's right go to
bluetooth.com fellas
you know sometimes
you go through some stress you go
through a little anxiety and your dick
is not
performing maybe how you'd like it's
called ed a lot of guys go through ed
you could just be old as [ __ ] if you're
watching this and your dick ain't
working like it did when you weren't
like 20. you know what i mean well
listen buchu
it is the wave uh how about this the
same active ingredients as viagra and
cialis getting delivered right to your
door in a chewable form in discrete
packaging and the best part about it is
it's all online zero awkward visits to
the doctor's office zero you go online
you sign up with the promo code bootleg
that's right bootleg when you check out
you will get the first month for free
all you gotta do is pay five dollars on
shipping and you're gonna get one
month's supply of blue chew all right
and you're gonna be [ __ ] like you
were [ __ ] never [ __ ] before your
dick's gonna
i'm gonna assume
you're adding at least a quarter of an
inch of erection that shit's gonna be
rocked up rocked up and sucked up all
right boys so what you need to do one
more time go to bluetooth.com and use
that promo code bootleg and get your
first month for free
bootleg promo code bootleg on
bluechoo.com let's get back to the
interview i remember uh what's the venue
in hollywood i can't think of the name
but it's the stadium yeah yeah the
palladium that nipsy sold out i remember
going to that first show you did and
when you pulled out that piano
exactly that was a moment bro yeah
appreciate that that was like i felt
like damn i'm going to remember this
[ __ ] in like 25 years i remember when
ronnie sold out the palladium after
nipsey did it you know said he pulled
out that piano i remember when i
did it with nip i actually ran into head
and he was like bro if i don't hear you
in the streets you suck like say some
[ __ ] like that
i was ready to look that [ __ ] ass shout
out to head man
i was ready with that [ __ ] feet bro
that's how i realized but
he was telling the truth like at the end
of the day that's how i treat it too now
like if i don't hear anything in the
streets if it ain't really buzzing like
that then it ain't making no noise a
[ __ ] can believe in some [ __ ] as well
that's another route but when you're in
that position where you could really
change a [ __ ] life with the situations
and the plugs you have you gotta see if
a [ __ ] wanted or not you know that's
real um
how many songs do you think you recorded
in the last two and a half years
countless bro i can't count like if you
is it more than 500 is it less than two
courses more than five it's more than
500 yes
is it close to it is it close to like
750
overnight
countless i'm telling you it's countless
i don't want to give a number and all he
recorded is countless because i i heard
that like uh
you know that you were just recording a
lot like recording yourself at home and
[ __ ] it's a lot bro all right at the end
of the day it's like
shooting in the gym i don't look at it
like how people look at it like oh it's
a money thing or you gotta put music out
and all this [ __ ] bro this is my
lifestyle that's what i do my music be
my therapy a lot of times you know to
give me a to stop thinking about should
i just lay it on the wax and it's cool
like it's over i i gotta think about it
no more somewhere i can listen to how i
feel
music is like therapy time slots too
where you can go back two years and
listen to yourself listen to your pitch
and where you was at and how you was
thinking and all that type of [ __ ] is
real
sometimes when you're recording you feel
like you're like it's more like a diary
for you like like yo this is just like
you could say that yeah you could say
that like i like like i might not ever
put this [ __ ] out but i know it's here
like i could always read it it's just
that's what i said it's a lifestyle bro
it ain't no
like i don't make music to be like i
gotta make a hit i gotta
bro this [ __ ] it's a lifestyle for me i
just do this [ __ ] bro it's like picasso
ain't paint like all my sale that [ __ ]
for i know he's just people he painted
because he loves it it's a lifestyle do
you engineer yourself at the crib i
can't that's good
what's the home setup is it just like a
uh
mbox or the uh what's the what's the
[ __ ] thing with the wheel the apollo
chris i have to tell you yeah engineer
shout out to chris he yeah yeah i have
to tell you because it doesn't got so
tedious at this point like it ain't like
we down there fly with a box of
you just have the studio in the box yeah
we have boxing so you could do the hotel
you could do whatever yeah we got the
whole
setup and then we recorded on the mic
and it's cool like i'll record outside
bro i tell a [ __ ] all the time but i'll
record in the dumpster bro is the c800
like your go-to vocal mic i i i i go
through i
you know i'll be
here and there whenever i want to hear
my voice a little different i just
try to figure out different different
different vibes and see how certain why
mike's is warmer right certain [ __ ]
sharper so i just be playing with [ __ ]
bro i just be trying to figure it out
myself it's just it's all the art
it ain't no specific way to do this [ __ ]
you know i mean a hundred percent man
yeah um
do we know like do we have any idea
any plans in terms of
an album another album
all these is ours at this point bro like
it's all albums it's all
music stream it's just all albums
i'm not a like it's mix tapes here
whatever it's mixtape's albums and
streams it's
whatever we just put it out and i hope
the fans love it more than anything
that's really my focus in making sure
the project is cohesive you found me
just whatever it is i just
because even from feed the streets the
first one is like just making sure it's
it's a body and it ain't just the head
over here the leg over there the the
[ __ ] foot over there the elbow
over there is like they got to make sure
that [ __ ] is cohesive and together
of course man and i feel like um
you got plaques off each of the tapes
right the first two tapes um i don't
feed the streets too is was yeah that's
the one i got i started getting [ __ ] on
um that one
um
we got a
late at night on the last one
i mean every every project i do my best
to give them some good music are you
fully like aware of like how much of a
classic album please excuse me for being
anti-socialist like are you aware of
like how almost like goddamn perfect
that project was like or does is it just
for you it's like hey it did what it was
supposed to do on to the next
yeah that's how i look at it i feel like
[ __ ] it's just what it is
and i know you know it's glory in it i
love it it's a great album i can still
listen to it to this day and that's what
the music is really about i feel like
that's what all your projects usually
strive for all your projects to be that
like can i still listen to this album
year after year and time at the time
that's what we shoot for yeah i feel
like uh
i haven't seen a project
carry for as long as that album did i
feel like it felt like it was like a
two-year run like we was man here at the
radio station we was playing god damn
the boxing high fashion and power
rotation damn near two years after the
[ __ ] ball and i know balls are on
that album but ballin still isn't power
rotation like every three weeks here at
real ninety two three it's like it's
crazy bro like the like your records
research in a way that is like not
normal
to like a radio audience it's [ __ ]
far
it's special man that's fine i
appreciate all the people listening and
you know y'all hold me down with this
[ __ ] you know i'm sure so i appreciate
everybody that's involved with that and
like i said bro i just make the music
that i want to hear a lot of the time so
that's why sometimes they change and we
go through our different phases in life
and [ __ ] and it's cool like
you know that's it's a lifestyle that's
why i'm pushing like it's more of a
lifestyle for me it's not
i'm trying to make this song be this
like that's why i feel like my music is
separated from a lot of other people
because i just make it based on where
i'm at
uh you kicked off the second album
sampling the kanye [ __ ] which was
cinematic as [ __ ] yeah great way to kick
that project that [ __ ] was that [ __ ]
gave me i was like oh man that [ __ ] had
me [ __ ] amped this because i i
remember i went and watched the new
spider-man movie because it came out you
remember the new spider-man movie
dropped the same day your album yeah i
got out from spider-man i threw that
[ __ ] on i was like whoa yeah
um
did you like get your i mean obviously
you and kanye have had a very well
documented friendship over the last
couple of years uh you being on donda
um
but was that something that you like
played for him let him know like hey you
know i kind of brought this joint back i
had told him the idea but i feel like in
that time and space i didn't get the
when i got it fully done i didn't get
the chance to play it for him fully done
rick ross somehow
he's in my top 10 but he's some somehow
underrated still i don't know how it is
when we think of like the all-time
greats i feel like not enough people say
his [ __ ] name yeah like
him he's himself like
ross if it wasn't for ross you know it
just
i felt like he held the streets down for
for a good minute and you feel me it's
just like i was his vibe and
he was just different and the maybach
music [ __ ] like that's why i bought my
maybach i seen nip have his maybach and
rick ross making the maybach music when
i was young before nip had a maybach it
was like when he did the maybach music
it was more so like
what is a maybach like what is that
yo that run when he had obviously
there's like deeper than rap but then
teflon dawn and the mmg project
self-made one and two
[ __ ] and shout out to gunplay who's also
underrated gunplay's a [ __ ] beast man
roddy i want to say bro
you could ask anybody uh your close
circle bird whoever
dallas i talk to everybody about you and
i want to say to you bro that you are a
special human being bro your your
artistry is crazy and i always tell
people is very i feel like it's almost
impossible for you to make a bad record
and there's not a lot of people who are
um
who i feel that way about
i feel like post malone is one of those
guys i just feel like your tone your
melodies and like i want you to know bro
[ __ ] what people think because i know
there was a point in time where you like
deleted the gram and you kind of were
off social media and you know i don't
know
whatever reasoning you had but like
man listen bro keep doing you bro i
appreciate that you know what i'm saying
yeah yes sir roddy rich boulet kev there
it is